how did you come up with this idea of  Highly stylized violence you know  there's all kinds of scenes that I  respond to in movies that respond to  music sequences I respond to Big comedy  sequences it was like they galvanized  the the entire theater everybody woke up  everybody got connected and I would go  see a film that had a sequence like that  I would see it two or three times at the  theaters just to see that sequence and  then just to have that experience with  an audience you're calling it violence I  you know it it is violence is also  action I think it's also kind of what  movies do in a way that's that's  particular to them as opposed to theater  or literature is you know the filming of  kinetic violence that can usually  usually they can have different reasons  for the impact but it can oftentimes  give a cathartic release for an audience